les agriculteurs français restent
vigilants une trentaine d'entre eux a
filtré aujourd'hui le trafic
marchandises du tunnel sous la manche
côté français afin de vérifier si
l'embargo sur le boeuf britanniques
étaient bien respectées il s'agit d'un
épisode de plus dans la véritable guerre
des nerfs que se livrent les deux pays
reportage de laurent n'avait et michel
van steenkiste
toujours
avoir une sécurité alimentaire maximum
aux avoirs consommateurs qu'ils soient
rassurés temps ces rachats il est
environ 16 heures au terminal fret du
tunnel sous la manche a calé une
cinquantaine d'agriculteurs rassemblés à
l'appel de la fnsea vérifie
systématiquement le contenu des camions
immatriculés en angleterre l'opération
vise à dénoncer le boycott plus ou moins
officiel des produits français sur le
territoire britannique c'est un appel ça
n'appelle en responsables britanniques
c'est un appel aux responsables aux
citoyens britanniques en disant vous
avez décidé des mesures de boycott oui
sachez que de notre côté on peut en
faire aussi et la pression elle possible
toute chose à manger
la pac
et la confrontation les autorités
anglaises avaient préféré bloquer elles
mêmes leurs camions qu'importe car pour
la fnsea cette opération était surtout
une occasion de justifier l'attitude de
la france face aux exportations de boeuf
il ya un embargo sur la viande
britannique ce n'est pas de notre fait
les scientifiques français qui ont
décrété que la viande de gotham et
comptait pas fiable à 100 % c'est tout
il faut respecter cette han et en europe
et pour respecter les règles du jeu
l'opération avant tout symbolique n'a
pas duré plus de quelques heures mais ce
soir le syndicat promettez de nouvelles
actions plus dures cette fois ci les
positions britanniques n'évolue pas
rapidement